And so a lot of initiation rights,
for example,
are predicated on the idea that you take the person out of their childhood
context,
you destroy their personality usually as a consequence of some traumatic and
counter and then you refill them with the cultural norms and that makes them an
adult.
And so,
you know,
to some degree,
that's what you guys are doing in a very slow way when you make the transition
from high school to university or the transition from high school to a,
to a job.
We don't,
in our culture,
we don't have the kind of abrupt ceremonies though that are designed to catalyze
that transformation.
And you know,
maybe that's an okay thing.
And then maybe it's not an okay thing.
I mean,
one of the things that Freud pointed out,
and he's absolutely right about this,
um,
is that because human beings have such a long dependency period,
it's not that easy for us to grow up.
And sometimes it takes a shock in order for that to happen.
And so one of the potential problems with having a dependency period as long as
the human dependency period is that it never ends and that you stay immature
forever.
And really I believe that that's the central problem that Freud talked about.
And I believe also that it's a real problem.
Now whether Freud formulated it with precise accuracy,
that's a different story.
But you know,
you gotta give the guy a break,
at least he formulated an and it's.
I mean I was much more impressed with Freud,
you depaul theorizing after I did clinical work for a long time because a large
number of my patients,
their primary problem is getting the hell out of their family.
They just can't do it.
And so for them the world is the family.
It's the only thing that matters.
It's often parental opinion or something like that.
They just cannot break free of it.
So you know,
initiation ceremonies in part were designed to catalyze that,
that break so that your,
your mother in particular,
but also your father to some degree.
We're no longer the dominant figures have influenced your personal mother and
father were no longer that dominant figures of influence in your life,
so because really that's what he maturation means in some sense is that when you
become an adult,
the opinions of your parents are as important as the opinions of any other
reasonable people that hypothetically care for you.
But no more important than that.